NARRATOR: In the South
Pacific, Lieutenant
Richard Nixon's air base has
been bombed for a solid month.
[gunshots]
[screaming]
After one raid, Nixon counts
35 bomb craters within 100
feet of his air raid bunker.
Must've had a tremendous
transformative effect
on Richard Nixon
realizing what it
truly means to be out in the
open, to have nowhere to hide.
[explosion]
Have no defenses.
[vomiting]
And that's part of
the World War II
experience for Richard Nixon.
He knows what combat is.
And later as commander-in-chief,
he's going to relive
those-- those moments.
You're tired,
you're exhausted.
And so of give back to a
place where you can just
relax and have something as
simple as a hot meal makes all
the difference in the world.
[music playing]
Nixon becomes a very
popular guy in World War II,
for the first time in his life.
Nixon was not a
naturally happy person,
but he seems to have
been about as happy
as he could get in wartime.
He opens Nix's
Snack Shack, and he's
able to give guys coming
back from the front
a little taste of home,
hamburgers and beer.
[laughter]
I was about the
most popular officer
in the South Pacific because
of that hamburger stand.
They were pretty good.
You could draw a parallel
between Richard Nixon's Snack
Shack and his later politics.
His going for things that
he knows are popular,
and that will win him political
points, get him into office,
and keep him in office.
He's wheeling and
dealing a little bit.
He's able to horse trade,
to swap Japanese rifles
for a bottle of whiskey.
He bends the rules in
order to get this stuff,
and bending the
rules seems to work.
He was now one of the guys.
He would play cards, and
in particular, poker.
My technique was to play
it very close to the vest.
I knew when to get
out of the pot.
I didn't stick around when
I didn't have the cards.
I didn't bluff very often.
[laughter]
He's shrewd.
He makes about $10,000,
which in-- in modern dollars,
is more like 100,000.
It's a lot of poker money.
Nixon is able to use it later on
to fund his political campaign.